it's discouraging what do you think what
rule don't know so now that we have all
the cameras together we can sync them up
but how do we do that I'm gonna start
rolling and they are rolling now sync it
with my helmet I've connected all of
them to this remote here somehow for
syncing it you can do like a visual way
like a clapper board sort of sound but I
don't know how you're supposed to clap
for something that's looking everywhere
so my solution was literally to take
this helmet drape it over hold it for
like a couple seconds then take it up
like eight feet I'm gonna say this is
this like 10 feet away here we are at 20
feet away actually probably closer to
like 30 feet if we're out in a public
spot I wouldn't really want to go any
further than this huh oh my god
first doors tested not good hardcore
badly stitched together today's Monday
we're shooting the main video on
Thursday and this is not promising tests
I've got basically two days to figure
this out we have to have a good solution
by the end of
and right now
sucks here you want to hold this
Luke Skywalker's lightsaber from a new
hope so Alan made this this is a
real-life lifesaver
okay so we turn on the toilet
yeah push it down on the passage that's
fine turn the fuel off close hotter I
want to try it first so what's your
stapler